Alejandro Toledo ya está en barbadillo
el expresidente de Perú fue recluido en
la cárcel en la que también se
encuentran los ex mandatarios Alberto
fujimori y Pedro Castillo allí deberá
permanecer 18 meses en prisión
preventiva la cárcel fue la última
parada de una movida jornada antes
Toledo se presentó a una audiencia de
verificación de identidad Alejandro
Toledo manrique toreo llegó a su país de
origen extraditado desde Los Ángeles
Estados Unidos después de entregarse las
autoridades peruanas venían pidiendo el
procedimiento desde 2018 el ex
mandatario es acusado de haber recibido
35 millones de dólares en sobornos de la
empresa brasileña odebrecht a cambio de
favorecerla para construir la ruta
interoceánica Sur que conecta Perú con
Brasil los cargos que recaen sobre el
mandatario son tráfico de influencias y
lavado de activos y probar que Alejandro
Toledo y todos
los funcionarios son culpables en la
capital peruana algunos seguidores le
manifestaron su apoyo a quien fue su
jefe de estado entre 2001 y 2006
nosotros tenemos justicia justa para
Alejandro Toledo
Toledo se convirtió en el segundo
expresidente extraditado después de que
fujimori lo fuera desde chile el ex
mandatario niega las acusaciones y sus
abogados y familiares habían pedido un
arresto domiciliario debido a su estado
de salud tengo entendido que los médicos
que lo han estado tratando allá en
Estados Unidos ya han dado un informe
que él padece de Cáncer y tiene que
hacer un chequeo minuciosos no la
tradición Toledo pidió la justicia
peruana que no lo dejen morir en la